well i think certainly it is true that
there is no imminent invasion but the
situation on the ground is extremely
unpredictable while the diplomacy moves
on
we're going to look at the sky
straighter now have a look up here to
the north of belarus now over the last
24 to 48 hours there have been more
russian military assets moving in there
there are long-range artillery there are
also sukhoi-35 jets as well
and what it means is that you now see
russian forces
pretty much surrounding ukraine in a
horseshoe uh to the east now down here
at donetsk and the hands this is a
contested area there is a concentration
of force also in crimea remember that
was annexed by russia also forces here
now does this mean that vladimir putin
is intent on invading the country
well it certainly gives him a number of
options he does have the possibility of
a full-scale invasion although the
ukrainian government says there simply
aren't enough forces here
somewhere in the region of 120 to 135
thousand uh troops in all but if he did
launch an invasion he could do that
coming down
from belarus
taking the capital kiev also perhaps
move uh troops up from the south as well
and then send them in
from the east as well that though is
highly unlikely uh remember of course
the kremlin says that the forces here
are mainly to do uh with military drills
going on and it has no intention of an
invasion so if we just take those arrows
off for the moment we could see another
possibility have a look again at the
contested region of donetsk and legends
here you could also potentially
see this frozen conflict being reignited
again that would uh be perhaps done
through covert operations and separatist
forces now it may also very well be that
vladimir putin decides to do nothing at
all he's certainly focused the minds
of western governments and also nato he
has his demands into them and remember
of course that this is really an
extension of what he is trying to
achieve as a policy he wants russia
recognized as a great power in a
multi-polar world and he also wants to
have really first say a greater russia
in the post-soviet space now is he going
to achieve that through negotiation
we'll wait and see
it's certainly a very unpredictable
situation on the ground but i think at
this moment vladimir putin has options
even if he hasn't himself decided what
he's going to do